[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait deux pas
plus qu'il ne faut trop d'écho beauté
bien sûr faux témoin au hasard par un
clown
attention ils ont manqué
[Musique]
personne n'est reparti trois parties à
ce genre de tous encore en passe d'être
sage pas ta zik et surtout non mais pas
monsieur bougon où tu vas toi faire le
marché bien sûr on donne moi ma petite
patate art t touche-à-tout tu cours
partout tu te perds et on met des heures
à leur prouver aller à tout à l'heure
pas plus de patate donc moi je manu
qu'est ce que j'aurais fait un jeu c'est
un pas tout tu sais que je ne suis pas
pas le bruit
quant à plusieurs passagers
moi je ne peux rien faire moi aussi de
la musique la musique c'est pas du bol
[Musique]
enfin le silence
cette fois ci
[Musique]
monsieur bourgault je faisais de la
musique de la musique que cha pas pas
plus que patache marque
je ne peux plus je n'en peux plus faire
de la musique
tant pis je vais être gentil je veux
ratissent le jardin ça fera plaisir à ma
petite papa tarp
je crains qu'ils font je j'entends bien
plus à la fille rentrait je t'ai
rapporté and illustrés ou au
c'est trop fort tu es content il te
plait oh oui c'est plein d'histoires
corsaire si tu as le temps est à l'orage
c'est pas le tanneur seller chez bougon
qui cogne
après qui je ne sais pas moi de toute
façon le jamais content nora to qui vole
encore une invention de potes à clous
cas l'imagination il a peut pas tacle où
chaque fois chine at ajoute j'ai la
fessée car l'engin en forme cieux
bourgon ne touchez pas à cet enfant
[Musique]
on vient 3g vous qu'il y ait de pâte à
pêcher le vôtre aux échos notez bien sur
vos droits
[Musique]